et maintenant j'accueille pascal sevran
pascal sevran bonsoir bonsoir alors
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont très copains ils
ont fait de la prison tous les de ma vie
non non jamel dans un film et gens qui
sortent pour de vrai donc ça crée des
liens ils ont vidé qui permet aux
changes cet enfant des prétoires est à
côté de ce trublion
ouais bah oui sont branchés qu'est ce
que c'est êtes vous l'homme curieux
ambitieux et cultivé à astrid en
cherchant oui mais bien sûr mais c'est
bien merci merci nous pourrons pas nous
en vouloir
comment ça va ça va à l'époque de
françois mitterrand vous êtes dû
beaucoup j'imagine pas beaucoup non ah
bon pour voir j'ai vu beaucoup gilbert
mais on s'est croisé quelques fois mais
ils étaient moins souvent à solutré mais
on s'est croisés mais je n'étais pas
solutré salue très souvent l'étranger
police est prise d'un côté c'est ce qui
dit oui il était voilà le moins
mitterrand des mitterrand vous faisiez
partie ce qu'on appelait les
mousquetaires du roi avec jack lang
pierre bergé kezman vous voyez toujours
les trois autres mousquetaires où ça
s'est un peu distendu les liens non je
vais je les vois bien sûr j'étais très
très content d'être avec eux j'étais
très fier de ça ouais mais aujourd'hui
je les vois souvent oui vous l'avez
aider quand il a été dans la merde là
vous imaginez bien que je vais pas vous
faire la révélation ce soit avec quoi
que ce soit j'ai pas parlé de ça ce soir
avant pour voir
non parce que c'est pas convenable j'ai
rien à dire sur ce sujet comme il était
en taule la juiverie j'ai entendu des 5
millions de francs est appelé en disant
moi je te file en supposant cher thierry
ardisson supposons que j'ai appelé oui
est ce que vous imaginez que je vais
vous dire ce soir que j'ai appelé messi
pour voir et ben non pas du tout et tout
le monde dit la vérité ici oui moi aussi
je vais le dire vous êtes appelés pour
mentir non mais vous savez il ya
beaucoup d'émissions de télévision on
parle beaucoup de tout le bien qu'on
fait toutes les belles choses qu'on fait
mais on veut parler de tout ça mélangé à
faire non non non non non je veux pas
dire oui du tout j'ai rien du tout j'ai
fait du bien c'est pas moi quand te
proposer la question je n'aime pas
beaucoup ça non voilà non mais tu irais
je voudrais pas du tout mais c'est pas
moi convenable vous pouvez pas de ces
choses-là bien bon alors
vous avez gardez vous en tous les cas
vous me l'avez dit ça une grande amitié
pour françois mitterrand malgré les
révélations sur son passé vichyste et
son amitié bousquet vous avez continué à
être son ami mais attendez il faut pas
prendre les grands mots françois
mitterrand a bien voulu que je sois pas
trop loin de lui et de sa famille ce qui
a été pour moi une grande émotion d'une
jeune homme que j'étais très
impressionné devant un homme de cette
densité
moi j'ai respecté je respecte encore
françois mitterrand y compris pour ceux
qu'on lui reproche
mais l'amitié avec bousquet par exemple
mais te d écouter les grands mots tout
cet avis sur notre époque
allez beaucoup bousquet voyait françois
mitterrand il avait la légion d'honneur
remise à sa bouton il avait été blanchi
les tigers et retirez vous savez tout
cela vous le faites redire alors je le
dis très tranquillement
françois mitterrand était tout sauf
antisémite françois mitterrand était
entouré de juifs magnifique j'ai eu dans
ma vie un maître à penser que ça plaît
emmanuel berl je me suis troublé en rien
enlever à ses proches à mi-terrain bien
alors vous vous l'avez appris quand sa
belle histoire de vichy le bouquin de
paix en tout ça je vais faire la même
réponse il s'évade trois fois il arrive
à vichy comme beaucoup de gens pour les
accuse pas d'être les schistes il est
dit la vente et quelques années il est
prisé de la guerre évadés il trouve il
travaille dans un service qui récupère
les prisonniers évadés et moins d'un an
plus tard on le trouve dans des réunions
de de résistance bien alors on va voir
on va parler de votre émission de
télévision c'est comment on fait comme
ça
donc voilà donc vous revenez sur france
2 oui demain à 12h05 ce mais ils nous
appellent chanter la vie
oui c'était bien la peine de vous virer
en même temps ça vous en parlez à vos
chefs thierry fontaine bien le lundi que
la gère des fréquences idée que michèle
cotta
moi j'ai pas été fâché je vais me
coucher j'ai un peu vinaigre quand même
non même pas parce que moi je peux pas
me déprendre du charme de michèle cotta
et puis j'ai beaucoup vu c'est une
grande journaliste alors évidemment elle
m'a eue au charme non ce n'était pas une
bonne idée qu'elle a beaucoup de charme
mais oui donc moi dès que je suis 2008
avec elle c'est ce qu'on fait des cons
et de mutek michèle cotta
on parle de françois mitterrand oui et
on en dit des choses gentilles alors la
première vous faites chez là c'est à
dire que dîtes moi en quoi c'est celle
défendre la chanson française
c'est une
je vais vous dire thierry c'est une
femme magnifique je trouvais qu'elle
était près de moi c'était bien elle va
chanter ce qui est plus original est
leur chanteuse depuis trois ans elle
avait fait son retour sur france 2 dans
mon émission
lorsqu'elle a chanté après ses adieux on
est devenus amis parce que c'est une
femme si bien je viens de le dire et je
lui dis coup devient entrevoit la
télévision chanter et moi j'aime bien
être un peu décalé puis c'est pour
chanter encore à montrer qu'à toi elle a
très gentiment
elle va chanter une chanson de mouloudji
et les chansons de brassens en direct
avec les musiciens
alors là je trouve que c est d'accord
vous venez chez là mais vous lui faites
chanter grand public et donc je trouve
que c'est bien cette tâche en plus
j'avais envie d'avoir que une femme de
cette qualité à côté de moi pour le
premier jour bon donc tout va bien quand
je parlais du patrimoine chanson
française il ya beaucoup il ya beaucoup
d'autres choses
il ya beaucoup de choses dans cette
émission si vous êtes réveillé où j'ai
traîné à mais je regarderai dans bien
sûr j'ai réveillé dimanche quand même
c'est fini cédric est mesurée à la télé
michel mallet dit faut que j'arrête de
boire et de fumer à vous connaissez
drucker fait pas que tu manges les pâtes
dont je mange des pâtes michel fait tout
ce que tu dis
il a cadré que je paierai pas ces tapis
rouge bon donc voila tu t'es under
control c'est demain voilà demain à midi
et puis ce sera tous les niveaux
franchis pas bien voilà le truc c'est un
peu mais ça va être une autre tonalité
parce qu'il ya jamais eu à cette
heure-là de variétés quoi alors puis le
public très mouvant il ya beaucoup de
gens une ou deux générations qui passe
voilà c'est un pari je vais le faire
très simplement avec montons à moi et
s'il ya des gens beaucoup qu'il regarde
très content bah ouais donc on regarde
tous pascal sevran dwi cela lui fera
plaisir mais ça ne va pas faire plaisir
à pascal sevran
c'est important non mais c'est vrai
alors vous continuez à écrire quand même
à tous les jours et beaucoup plus
courageux que - ah oui ça je disais à
mon éditeur
il faut trouver le temps un pas mais
comment vous faites ce merveilleux
d'arrivée c'est à dire que je j'ai bien
organisés les trucs quoi je déjeune je
déjeune pas donc c'est déjà depuis très
longtemps
tu avais des économies ça fait mincir là
ça permet d'écrire oui c'est pas mal et
puis oui parce qu'elle crée ce très
importante donc j'écrivais avant la
télévision j'écris pendant la télévision
j'ai écrit va très probablement après et
là c'était un moyen d'expression
différents
si on veut venir me trouver on vient me
trouver dans mes livres c'est un petit
peu différent et j'ai besoin de cet
équilibre entre le métier public
nous sommes là en temps de bavarder
joyeusement et puis le silence de
l'écriture qui compte beaucoup pour moi
mais ça marche les gens viennent vous
retrouver comme vous dites là le dernier
bouquin est vendu combien 200 milles
c'est énorme et ça fait du pognon très
bien non mais je n'écris les livres pour
jeunes j'allume oui oui mais vous avez
raison et on écrit pour votre show
matinal sur tout et surtout suilhard
plus surtout celui-là sociaux alors vous
dites je publierai un nouveau livre tous
les 4 janvier oui jusqu'à ce que je ne
sois plus en état de le faire pas mal
comme idée je pensais à ça tous les 4
janvier on sait voilà c'est à dire que
le 5 janvier s'est invitée dans
l'émission on dit outre pourquoi le
catch est pas c'est une date
anniversaire de la naissance de stéphane
donc je rêvais que comme le premier est
sorti comme ça c'était de jolis je suis
pas très petit schiste mais je trouvais
que c'était c'est un symbole quoi
trouver que c'était vous est remis de ce
drame non je suis content de chanter je
concevais
non mais vous avez l'air quand nana là
ça va ça va mais vous prenez sur vous
mais oui il faut se tenir convenablement
sens montre pas la division et puis les
gens qui regardent sont contents non
puis je suis en vie ouais c c'est tout à
fait étonnant d'être en vie quoi alors
je de ce à quoi c'est pas mal le fait
d'être en vie c'est pas mal vous et
déménager quand même ah oui hein mais je
suis content c'est bien l'île saint
louis
oui c'est très très bien je suis comme
un fou je vais plus parler du tout un
mail à lâcher le vrai pari là bah oui là
je suis comme un lâche une carte postale
l'arrêt à oui c'est plus qu'on peut
imaginer ces s'était jamais aller avant
mais je voulais battre tout le temps là
je suis comme ouais comme un gamin qui
joue avec les bateaux sur la scène c'est
très très beau mais qu'est ce qui se
passe la vie
ils voulaient faut tout je vous conte
c'est quoi cette histoire là et non mais
moi je sais mixer quelques avances voilà
puis-je émotions oui parce que jean
christophe qui commence est jaloux
l'habiter ronde